on est en finale le rêve s'est réalisé
plus de trois cent cinquante mille
personnes se sont rassemblés la nuit
dernière sur les champs-elysées pour
fêter l'événement après le but de
libérateur de lilian thuram le héros du
match
on imagine aisément la fête dimanche
soir six points de suspension mais
n'anticipons pas madame monsieur bonsoir
pour voir les français remporté leur
demi finale contre la croatie 2-1 c'est
presque toute la france qui était hier
soir devant sa télévision
17 millions de téléspectateurs qui ont
d'abord tremblé avant de laisser éclater
leur joie jamais dans l'histoire de la
coupe du monde l'équipe de france
n'avait dépassé le stade des demi
finales
le premier à s'en réjouir l'entraîneur
aimé jacquet reportage yann lavoix andré
germain il en a rêvé ils l'ont fait eux
ce sont ses joueurs son groupe comme il
dit avec ses mots à lui la buée dans les
lunettes aimé jacquet voit pourtant bien
à l'autre bout du terrain lilian thuram
porté en triomphe et longtemps encore
aimer se souviendra de ses deux buts
inscrits incroyable thuram dont jacques
est dit souvent qu'il a les pieds carrés
et comprenez qu'il est maladroit devant
le but
tous les matins je lui disais toi tu me
marquent à jamais un but or je suis très
mal aujourd'hui il nous en a marqué deux
je crois que lilian thuram a été l'image
de 7,7 cette équipe c'est à dire de la
générosité du talent et puis une envie
folle de se surpasser de et puis de
renverser des situations thuram héros
ordinaire entame un tour d'honneur lui
qui est cet homme de devoir comme les
aime aimer un leader discret et puis il
ya toute cette joie immense vécu
simplement par des stars qui n'en sont
pas je me suis aperçu que les joueurs
ont été très humble très calme ça veut
dire qu'ils nous préparent quelque chose
pour dimanche
bien sûr avant la délivrance mais a eu
peur surtout lorsque choucair a ouvert
la marque pour la croatie
toutacoo revenait en mémoire les images
de 58 2 82 et 86 et trois demi finales
perdues mais il y avait 80 milles
poitrine qui voulaient infléchir le
cours du match
le cours de l'histoire ce public cette
france à laquelle il voudrait tant donné
et mai
on à réconcilier la france grâce au
football je pense que le français qui
est un égoïste
ben il va venir peut-être un peu plus
collectivement et qui va peut-être faire
la fête ensemble
c'est peut-être le seul point positif
que l'on va apporter
et si on pouvais je dirais le poursuivre
dans notre vie de tous les jours pour
que les gens soient plus heureux plus
plus fier d'être français et peu fiers
d'être des foudres de leur équipe de
foot
il est comme ça et mais généreux
partageur affamés de joie collective et
l'exclusion de laurent blanc l'a empêché
de goûter goulûment à la victoire au
plaisir d'être en finale de la coupe du
monde
au coup de sifflet final il reste seul
il réalise qu'il lui fallait cette
finale pour faire enfin l'unanimité
parmi les supporters mais aussi parmi
les journalistes des journalistes qui à
sa grande surprise nous ont fait une
ovation ce matin avant sa conférence
j'apprécie beaucoup et jamais il n'a
parlé de revanche mais on n'a pas fini
bien sûr à 21h hier soir au moment du
coup d'envoi la plus belle avenue du
monde les champs elysées était
pratiquement déserte
trois heures plus tard elle était noire
de monde 350 mille personnes environ
fêtant dans la bonne humeur et sans
incident la victoire de l'équipe de
france
siri curtet burning une folie douce tout
simplement nous étions
trois cent cinquante mille à venir nous
enivrer d'allégresse de bonheur de joie
une sauvage envie de partager un moment
dont on se rappellera
on est en finale à l'unisson 350 mille
personnes pour quatre mots magiques
répéter à l'infini sur les deux
kilomètres deschamps je disais de la
concorde à l'arc de triomphe la foule
cobac n'est qu'une bouche
une fête improvisée aujourd'hui c'est la
fausse gagnent la finale je sais pas où
robinson comment ce soit le chemin nous
aiment ce sera catastrophique
sa plus belle journée du foot français
c'est ma prochaine la plus belle journée
un immense soulagement après 90 minutes
dong hwa
promesse d'une autre fête à venir qui le
sera que champagne comme si l'essentiel
avait été accomplie le sort pour jurer
le rêve a duré jusque tard dans la nuit
ou tôt ce matin mal de tête gueule de
bois extinction de voix
il ne reste pourtant que quatre jours ou
plutôt quatre nuits pour se refaire une
santé et être prêt pour le feu
d'artifice final
le héros de la soirée hier n'est pas un
habitué des plus beaux titres
lilian thuram donc à plutôt en général
le rôle essentiel mais ingrat de
défenseurs ce cas hier soir il n'avait
même jamais marqué un but en équipe de
france
et coup sur coup deux exploits faisselle
bertrand aurait germé
l'équipe de fond son final c'est
historique
lilian thuram défenseur qui marque c'est
inédit et de lutte c'est héroïque du mal
à réaliser quand même parce que bon
marque fait marquer deux buts pour moi
c'est quelque chose de l'invraisemblable
parce que bon déjà à l'entraînement jean
marc pas d'habitude dans un match on a
l'image le son du commentateur mais
jamais le commentaire du but et se
demande toujours ce qui peut bien se
passer dans la tête d'un joueur qui
marque turan ou le dit le ballon rentre
et je me dis ah là là là c'était trop je
me dis mais attends je me dis attentat
marque et cc c'est pas possible
et je vois tout le monde se tait sur moi
et je réalisais pas et puis j'entends un
joueur qui dit laissez le respirer mais
en fait c'était ça a laissé respirer
parce que un peu plus je dire je tombe
dans les pommes pas la limite voix
et en plus le deuxième but c'était
vraiment je me disais mon qu'est ce qui
t'arrive jeudi route et mais marcel mais
marcel michelin ferment m bio qu'est ce
qui se passe je dis moi j'en sais rien
ce qui se passe à la en fait il n'ya
même pas de choix c'est l'étonnement que
je pense qu'il faudra attendre moins de
30 ans encore pour que cauchemar la
maire de lille lyon a vécu le match en
direct avec son fils elle vit en région
parisienne l'émotion chez les thuram
cette famille je m'y attendais pas c'est
tout cela à ce moment je me suis évanoui
puis oui oui je me suis venu parce que
je m'attendais pas lyon a renoué avec
son père depuis peu joseph via ans
bertrand en guadeloupe
il porte le même numéro de son fils qui
avant d'être footballeur était
marathonien la course à pied peut mener
loin
quand tu as du courage tu vas très très
loin le courage ce moral c'est ça qui a
mené l'équipe à la victoire
le football aussi ça peut mener loin
ça peut aussi changer quelqu'un avant
d'être joueur ligne on voulait être
prêtre
il quitte la guadeloupe à 9 ans et à
fontainebleau qu'il change de vocation
l'illumination sera pour le balourd
surnommé jambes d'allumettes
il va rester à l'as monaco jusqu'en 96
et puis s'il n'y a pas remis dès sa
première saison
thuram est élu meilleur défenseur du
calcio une référence
hier il a écrit la plus belle page de
son histoire qui coïncide avec celle du
football français à 26 ans lilian thuram
accompli un exploit pour l'équipe de
france qui s'est au final un miracle est
si vite arrivé une seule fausse note
malheureusement hier soir mais
d'importance en vue de la finale contre
le brésil l'équipe de france a perdu
l'un de ses rouages essentiels
laurent blanc victime d'un carton rouge
et d'une expulsion plus que contestable
qui lui valent deux matches de
suspension en équipe nationale l'arbitré
espagnol qui l'a sanctionné n'en est pas
à sa première décision litigieuse
laurent frédéric bollée florent autre
pour les arbitres aussi une demi finale
de coupe du monde est un rendez vous à
ne pas rater
rose emmanuel garcia aranda qui avait
déjà dirigé ni à un mois le match
d'ouverture brésil écosse signe à priori
d'excellence a provoqué hier une
polémique avec l'expulsion de laurent
blanc que le croate slaven bilic se
tienne le front haut lieu du menton ne
fait aucun doute qu'il en rajoute
beaucoup également
d'un autre côté blanc a bien touché voir
frapper son adversaire
là où il s'attendait un carton jaune
laurent blanc reçoit en fait un carton
rouge dont le moins que l'on puisse dire
est qu'il est très sévère il n'y aura
pas de finale pour le défenseur français
c'est vrai que la dernière faute c'est
moi qui la commet mais j'ai passé qu'il
avait m en carton jaune donc quand j'ai
vu le carton rouge
il y avait plus rien à faire il y avait
assumé cette décision à respecter ces
décisions là et à sortir du terrain
malheureusement le joueur et sportif
larbitre peut être injuste car monsieur
aranda 42 ans professeur d'éducation
physique
arbitre depuis 28 ans avait déjà fait
parler de lui dans ce mondial lors du
match pays bas yougoslavie c'est lui qui
contrairement à hier n'avait pas sorti
le carton rouge pour une faute
autrement plus graves de l'attaquant de
l'as berck ans c'est toujours monsieur
aranda qui avait refusé à lilian
laslandes et à auxerre un superbe but en
ligue des champions il ya un peu plus
d'un an des décisions parfois étonnant
de la part de l'espagnol mais les
arbitres on le sait est souverain c'est
l'appréciation de l'arbitré
il faut lui faire confiance toujours est
il que larbi a pris cette décision en
son âme et conscience
sept arbitres n'avaient aucun a priori
ni à langon des croates ni à l'encontre
des français
il a pris cette décision il a pris ses
responsabilités et sans état d'âme donc
monsieur aranda prive un joueur réputé
exemplaire d'une finale de coupe du
monde
une cruelle déception pour laurent blanc
un coup dur pour l'équipe de france et
c'est un arbitre marocain said belgo là
qui dirigera dimanche la finale entre le
brésil et la france il a déjà arbitré
deux rencontres de cette coupe du monde
allemagne etats unis et allemagne croise
un homme prend sa revanche en ce moment
là déjà entendu tout à l'heure c'est
l'entraîneur des bleus aimé jacquet
critiqué voire moqué avant le début de
la compétition par certains il est
aujourd'hui le premier entraîneur qui
est amené la france en finale d'une
coupe du monde
aimé jacquet a peut-être le tort de ne
pas être un homme à la mode c'est
peut-être aussi là le secret de sa
réussite florent gautreau andré germain
dans les yeux d'aimé jacquet il y a
beaucoup de joies du soulagement et
aussi de l'émotion
lui qui se présente toujours comme un
homme du terroir a dû penser très fort
hier soir aux gens de ça ils sont
cousins dans le village de la loire qui
l'a vu grandir
on n'oublie pas les attaques qu'il a dû
subir peur est la presse et en
particulier le journal l'équipe n'a pas
été tendre avec jacquet depuis deux ans
on lui a tout reprocher ses choix
tactiques ses choix de joueurs et même
son manque de charisme
je crois qu'on sait moins tromper clé
beaucoup moins trompé et que on fera les
comptes en suisse et la france est
championne du monde on n'en a l'air de
s'être trompée je crois qu'on sera pas
trompés parce que si elle est championne
du monde sait qu'elle a joués et qu'elle
a fait ce qu'on dit depuis trois ans
aujourd'hui la france est en finale
grâce à thuram grâce à jacques est aussi
forcément ce matin ses détracteurs se
rétracte un peu mais jacquet lui n'a pas
oublié
il ya une réalité professionnelle on ne
bafoue pas les gens qui travaillent
c'est tout jamais je suis extrêmement
heureux parce que le public français a
très bien vu qu'on l'a trompée depuis
deux ans et maintenant il a une grande
équipe de france mais nous on
l'annonçait depuis longtemps homme de
terroir homme de terrain jacques et
n'écoute que ses amis les techniciens et
les éducateurs et il est peut être en
train de gagner son pari avec l'équipe
de france comme il l'avait gagné avec
les girondins de bordeaux champions de
france où sa direction
et quoi qu'il arrive dimanche l'ancien
ouvrier retournera chez lui dans la
loire avec le sentiment du devoir
accompli
pour en arriver pour arriver jusqu'en
finale l'équipe de france aura eu un
parcours facile dans un premier temps et
beaucoup plus éprouvant pour les nerfs
des joueurs et des spectateurs à partir
des huitièmes de finale mathieu ch
bleu blanc rouge marseille accueille la
france le coeur serré on retient son
souffle avant que les deux inséparables
zidane et dugarry toujours le bal trois
danses à 0 contre l'afrique du sud
un petit tour à paris et un beau doublé
d'henry contre l'arabie la balade
continue 10 ou laisse traîner une
semelle carton rouge
le chef des enquêtes des tricolores est
suspendu pour deux matches mais ne
boudons pas notre plaisir
la france marque 4 à 0
france danemark la première place du
groupe est en jeu bien dosée et bien
tiré djorkaeff le régional de l'étape
ouvre le score
le même de l'autre côté barthez encaisse
son premier but avant que petit le
costaud voit rouge
les choses sérieuses vont commencer
je voulais
prolongations barthez trouve le temps
long nous aussi la plaisanterie a assez
duré et blanc est bien de 7 à 10 but en
or contre le paraguay
arthez encore lui mais cette fois ci
contre l'italie la france n'avait jamais
trouvé aussi jolie leçon d'un ballon
écrasé sur une transversale de sailly
peut décoller destination la finale avec
une escale en demie les premiers
intéressés au match d'hier soir était
bien entendu les brésiliens dans tout le
pays on a suivi avec attention le match
et observer ces français que l'on aime
bien et que l'on voudrait tout même bien
battre dimanche prochain à paris
christophe duchiron franzen ces filières
au moment de france croatie il ya du
monde dans la rue c'est un arrêt de bus
et en attendant le bus ils regardent le
match à la télé on sait plus pour passer
le temps qu autre chose en matière de
football
le brésilien s'intéresse au brésil et
rien qu'au brésil et si on s'intéresse à
l'adversaire si pour le foot qu'il faut
être que ça pourrait être la croatie en
finale car la france termine ma réaction
il ne pense qu'à ça
ils se sont réunis au bureau pour suivre
la rencontre de l'hexagone au brésil
c'est la diagonale du foot
un petit coin de folie française en
terre brésilienne
lilian thuram vient d'égaliser
paris/marseille chaumont maubeuge où rio
de janeiro tout ce que la france compte
de supporters est aux anges
plus de dix mille kilomètres séparent la
france et brésil mais d'hier tous les
français et est assise sur la même
tribune pour encourager les bleus
thuram encore marié et la france va
gagner
france-brésil la finale donc ils font
tant rêver les français de rio au coeur
bleu blanc de coups de génie thuram et
puis barthez qui veut les arrêts
fantastiques
les brésiliens ont une confiance dans
nos équipes extraordinaire ils nous
souhaitent depuis le début d'être
vice-champion on va essayer d'en montrer
qu'on a une chance d'être champion
ce matin avant d'aller à l'école
les gamins de copacabana sont venus
taper dans le ballon brésil france le
petit brésilien comme son aîné son coeur
et jaune et vert est le résultat de la
finale ne fait aucun doute
le brésil va gagner 3 0 et ronaldo va
ridiculiser zidane dimanche le brésil va
l'emporter j'espère que ronaldo mettra
autant buts il en a déjà marqué la vie
du brésil on peut dire que les résidents
n'attend pas la finale il attend de la
victoire remarqué en france ça doit être
pareil
après un bref moment de décontraction la
nuit dernière et ce matin encore
l'équipe de france se concentre sur la
finale nous aussi les joueurs français
conscients de la valeur de leurs
adversaires mais relativement serein à
ce niveau tous les espoirs sont permis
coûte on les sait pas pour surestimer
les français ou pour mettre en valeur un
certain chauvinisme mais je crois qu'on
est l'équipe qui a montré le plus de
coeur sur le terrain maintenant temps
qualité de jour proprement dit les
brésiliens sont très forts ils ont
beaucoup d'individualités mais nous nous
formons un groupe très solide
ça va être un match très difficile je
crois que les brésiliens sont depuis
ce n'est plus très bien présente à une
nation trop de lumière
donc ce sera à nous aussi de les embêter
le plus possible puis on verra
maintenant un match reste un match je
crois qu'ils sont pas ils sont pas
imbattables
c'est la finale idéale c'est la finale
la finale magique parce que parce que le
prêtre le brésil ça représente beaucoup
dans l'esprit des gens et parce que
c'est une coupe du monde en france et
que la france la joue pour la première
fois de l'histoire du football français
maintenant tout ce qui arrive je dirais
c'est du bonus on rencontre le brésil ce
qui se fait de mieux mais bon on va pas
s'avouer vaincu je crois qu'on respecte
cet adversaire mais je pense qu'on a les
moyens aussi de les battre la condition
physique sera déterminante dimanche pour
la finale ça on s'en doute le médecin de
l'équipe de france sans citer de nom a
estimé aujourd'hui que plusieurs joueurs
ont déjà puisé dans leurs réserves
on verra bien les brésiliens de leur
côté ont bénéficié d'une journée
supplémentaire de repos
sébastien guibert bruno livertout voilà
plus d'un mois qu'ils viennent assister
aux entraînements de l'équipe du brésil
visiblement il ne s'en lasse pas mais
dimanche ce sera une autre histoire ses
joueurs tant adulé affronteront l'équipe
de france beau dilemme pour les
supporteurs
bonjour qui tu supportes en fait la
france la france
les sox s'il brésil et gagner c'est
quand même le maillot pour la france
alors les publics et sans bail tous les
moteurs sont faciles c'est clair de la
sympathie pour les y compris les
amateurs de beau jeu ne voit donc pas la
finale comme une simple confrontation
mais bien comme la promesse d'un
spectacle mémorable
le maire d'ozoir compte d'ailleurs
rebaptisé le stade des trois sapins
stade daf arènes du nom du gardien de
but brésilien
il est moins connu grenat vidéo c'est
sûr mais c'est la vie pourront rendre
hommage à l'équipe du brésil car on
freine plaque commémorative en même
temps qu'il dira qu'il voyait s'est
entraîné pour la coupe du monde de 98 du
22 mai au 10 juillet dans la carrière au
brésil
ozoir est devenue l'une des villes
françaises les plus célèbres
cette notoriété a plongé les habitants
de la commune dans une telle euphorie
qu'ils peinent encore à réaliser que
l'équipe de france jouera elle aussi en
finale est à noter que ronaldo la
vedette de l'équipe ne s'est pas
entraîné aujourd'hui il souffre d'une
d'un coup à la cheville droite c'est ce
qu'ont indiqué des médecins de l'équipe
du brésil pour autant il n'est pas
déclaré forfait pour dimanche la fête
hier soir après la victoire de l'équipe
de france ne se déroule et pas seulement
sur les champs-elysées comme on l'a vu
tout à l'heure mais dans des dizaines de
villes françaises des supporters ont
chanté et dansé une bonne partie de la
nuit eric mézil
alain location il marée humaine
avait rendez vous avec la lune on lui
avait promise elle l'a décrochée
a bordeaux etait-il vingt mille trente
mille personnes ne les a comptés ont
préféré s'inventer le tube de l'été
la tension était trop fort que le stress
est enfin évacué le feu sacré les
supporters à lille l'entretiennent aussi
la nuit brûle on se rafraîchit comme on
peut c'est l'heure du bain de minuit
et comme par magie
ces drapeaux qui ressort qui s'agitent
offrant le spectacle d'un 14 juillet un
peu en avance grâce bourg perd le nord
cinquante villes du sud et fait sa
corrida
ouais
allez un dernier baiser pour la route et
direction lyon ici aussi on a vibré en
musique au rythme de tout le pays
lui d'ivresse une nuit de folie toute la
france en thermique ou en cravate aller
ce sens retenu exploser sa joie
en marge de la compétition sportive le
mondial a engendré une autre forme de
compétition plus feutrée celle là entre
le premier ministre et le président de
la république qui depuis le début du
mois de juin soit dit respectueusement
se marquent à la culotte comme disent
les spécialistes damien thévenot vincent
foucades coup de sifflet final hier soir
les bleus l'emportent
l'entraîneur est ni jacquet est soulagé
jacques chirac ex août
c'est vraiment une belle histoire qui
démarre sur la pelouse de clairefontaine
les bleus s'entraînent le mondial n'a
pas encore commencé mais déjà le
président chirac occupe le terrain sur
l'ailé gauche
la réaction est immédiate le gardien de
la majorité reprend la balle au bond
confidence j'ai commencé ma carrière
sportive comme ball effectivement avant
de passer au basket
arrêtez les buts comme barthez les uns
l'ont fait les autres en rêve
oui la france bat le danemark qui va
rencontrer l'italie en quart de finale
on voyage officiel à sienne le premier
ministre joue auto tokyo avec son
homologue italien
mais à l'autre bout du monde au
mozambique jacques chirac a déjà montré
qu'il est le premier les supporters
c'est le plus heureux des hommes
et j'ai reçu des félicitations qui m'ont
touché droite au coeur de la part du
président chissano
je l'en remercie la france bat l'italie
aux tirs au but forcément un tel exploit
s'apprête à la métaphore je suis un
entraîneur joueur 10 et les annonces de
jacquet et de zidane
un président et un premier ministre qui
ne seront pas les derniers à célébrer la
victoire de la france si tout se passe
bien dimanche soir l'effet mondial ou
celui de la bonne santé économique du
moment en france jacques chirac et
lionel jospin sont au firmament des
sondages selon le baromètre ipsos le
point le président que 68% d'opinions
favorables contre 53 le mois dernier et
70% de français ont une bonne opinion de
lionel jospin contre 60 le mois
précédent les incendies autour de
marseille s'était calmée ce matin après
avoir parcouru plusieurs centaines
d'hectares de garrigue nécessité à la
présence d'un millier de sauveteurs et
l'évacuation temporaire de plusieurs
centaines de personnes mais
malheureusement un nouveau départ de feu
s'est déclaré cet après midi dans la
région d'aix-en-provence sur place
yannick aroussi les pins et des chênes
s'enflamme comme des allumettes
le front de l'incendié avance
inexorablement pour les 400 pompiers au
sol le combat au corps à corps éthérique
faut éviter que le feu ne gagne du
terrain mais dans ce relief accidenté
des collines de peigner les soldes sont
nombreux
il y a du monde et des avions
mais malgré l'intervention massive d'une
quinzaine d'appareils le front de flamme
large de frais de 2 km progresse vers le
département du var tout proche
des données moyennes aérienne ou
cantonaux comme disons le sinistre mais
il est loin d'être maîtrisée et
également d'être circonscrit des
renforts sont arrivés des départements
voisins mais l' incendie se propage
rapidement dans la forêt pourtant
l'alerté a été donnée dès le départ du
feu
sur le départ ya donc une propriété
privée tout bon ça y est sûre sans
l'aide de l'âge de départ simplement
à la limite et débroussailler les
flammes ont parcouru environ 400
hectares il faut faire vite mettre en
place le maximum de moyens avant le
crépuscule lincendie de penny reste le
seul foyer préoccupant dans le
département le feu du massif des
calanques de marseille ne donne plus
d'inquiétude et laisse derrière lui un
paysage de désolation sormiou morgiou de
des bijoux de la côte sont touchés mais
il n'y a eu aucune victime
hier les autorités avaient fait évacuer
360 personnes et un pyromane d'une
quinzaine d'années a été interpellé
aujourd'hui même cet après midi à
marseille alors qu'il enflammé des
buissons une commission parlementaire a
présenté aujourd'hui un rapport très
critique pour ne pas dire plus sur le
fonctionnement des tribunaux de commerce
en france une justice bénévole rendu par
des commerçants des industriels qui dans
certains cas même justice et intérêts
personnels c'est ce que dénonce la
commission mais l'opposition
parlementaire estime que l' on
généralise à partir de quelques affaires
condamnable olivier caroff valait rien
c'était l'un des temples de la nuit
parisienne du palace il ne reste
aujourd'hui que la façade est une
affaire plutôt embarrassante pour le
tribunal de commerce de paris
la boîte de nuit pourraient être
rachetées aux enchères par un ancien
juge du tribunal cet homme qui sort
discrètement de la salle des ventes a
proposé 7 millions et demi de francs
seul problème pendant trois ans ses
collègues ont refusé une autre offre
largement supérieure à la sienne
un cas exemplaire de dysfonctionnements
au sein des tribunaux de commerce c'est
en tout cas l'avis du groupe de députés
chargés d'enquêter sur cette justice
rendue par des juges élus est venue du
monde de l'entreprise
leur rapport évoque des soupçons de
corruption des juges au comportement
douteux et des mandataires de justice
qui penseraient avant tout à l'argent
que leur mission peut leur apporter
il faut comprendre que les mandataires
qui n'ont pas été encadrées en lui trop
de tentations
trop d'argent ou trois l'argent des
cimes c'est pas le leur plus ils sont
responsables mais les juges sont très
responsables ne pas avoir contrôlé des
propos qui soulève un tollé de la part
des juges comme des mandataires même si
certains ne cachent pas que le ménage
aurait bien besoin d'être fait au sein
des tribunaux comme il y un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont des
affairistes et qui sont de tous les
métiers ne sont pas d'ailleurs
spécialement
des juges consulaires non non pour la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
l'une des solutions serait de faire
entrer des juges professionnels dans les
juridictions commerciales
on appelle ça des cheveux vinage à
nanterre les juges du tribunal de
commerce rappelle eux qu'ils sont
bénévoles
ils n'ont pas envie d'être dirigé par un
fonctionnaire de l'état
si par exemple via un juge professionnel
qui qui préside la chambre que choisit
actuellement je dirais c'est très bien
qu'il fasse son travail moi j'irai faire
autre chose ailleurs et menace brandie
par la plupart des présidents de
tribunaux de commerce de france
ils attendent désormais l'arbitrage du
gouvernement et se disent prêts à
refuser de siéger à partir du 1er
janvier 1999
en corse le président de la caisse
locale du crédit agricole de la région
de bastia joseph barratier et écroué
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la sphère
plus générale du fonctionnement de la
caisse régionale du crédit agricole en
corse
le ministre de l'intérieur jean pierre
chevènement installé ce matin la
commission chargée d'examiner les
dossiers des sans papiers qui n'ont pas
été régularisée dans les délais les cas
seront examinés individuellement il n'y
aura pas de régularisation collective
comme le réclament les associations en
pointe dans cette affaire alors que les
autorités algériennes annonce une
nouvelle fois la mort d'un chef
important du gia les groupes islamistes
un nouvel attentat à la bombe a fait 10
morts et une vingtaine de blessés ce
matin à alger n'y avait pas eu
d'attentât depuis un certain moment
cette explosion ait lieu le jour même où
une nouvelle manifestation contre
l'arabisation du pays étaient organisées
thierry thulliez bruno girodon
c'est comme si rien ne s'était passé
quelques heures à peine après l'attentât
il ne reste que c'est un pagne et
quelques vitres brisées là où la bombe a
explosé faisant au moins dix morts
le quartier du ruisseau est un des plus
populaires d'alger et le marché aux
puces était très fréquenté ce jeudi
matin
d'après les commerçants du groupe 1
souligne l'intéressé avait beaucoup de
monde pour maintenant l'avocat demande
par alger qui tremble et alger qui
manifestent à l'appel d'un parti
d'opposition le front des forces
socialistes
fortement implanté en kabylie la marche
est autorisée ils sont plusieurs
milliers à défiler
ils disent non la réalisation mais ne
veulent surtout pas être contenu à la
défense de la seule cause kabyle
aujourd'hui les manifestants sont sortis
dans la rue vous si monter cette unité
nationale et qu'on arrête d'essayer de
focaliser aisé de dépasser le débat soit
disant entre kabyle arabe qui est un
faux débat qui se passe nous demandent
de la paix la frappe mais pour ça il
doit y avoir de dialogue compte en eau
leur algérie est plurielle à la fois
berbère arabophones et francophones
ils veulent croire que la loi sur la
généralisation de l'arabe ne sera jamais
à pic
la russie attend toujours une nouvelle
aide du fonds monétaire international
subordonnée à une véritable reprise en
main de l'économie
car à l'heure actuelle il ya d'un côté
les milliards voyant de l'économie
mafieuse et puis des dizaines de
milliers d'ouvriers qui ne sont plus
payés et puis des dizaines d'entreprises
encore qu'ils ne payent pas leurs impôts
le pays donne l'impression de ne plus
être gouvernés reportage gilles rabin
from brisset mondiale oblige la russie
qui gagne séparés en ce début d'été des
couleurs de la france
c'est le dernier centre commercial de
luxe qui s'est ouvert à moscou
les galeries françaises mais le vrai
baromètre du pays est ailleurs dans les
nouveaux hypermarchés comme vous l'avez
vu pour certains produits c'est mon cher
ici que sur les marchés du quartier
6 pourquoi notre éventail de clientèle
va des retraités ou lyonnais la crise
financière frappe la russie au moment où
commençait à apparaître
enfin une vraie classe moyenne car
aujourd'hui il ya de russie celle qui
n'a plus besoin d'état et celles qui en
dépend toujours pour ses factures et
pour ses salaires le nouveau
gouvernement veut faire payer la
première pour permettre à la deuxième de
survivre encore en russie l'impôt est
très lourd et la fraude fiscale un vrai
sport national s'attaque d'abord aux
plus riches prennent sens puisque ce
sont eux qui ont le plus d'argent il
faut commencer par même si certains ont
beaucoup de pouvoir
il n'y aura pas d'intouchables la même
politique
on sera appliqué à tous pour montrer sa
détermination il n'a pas hésité à faire
de gazprom sa première victime le numéro
un mondial du gaz naturel doit plus de
10 milliards de francs à la russie mais
la russie et ses monstres industriel
hérité du soviétisme doivent encore plus
à gazprom en factures de gaz impayées
ils dansent les mineurs qui campent
depuis un mois devant l'immeuble du
gouvernement russe
mais ils savent que leurs mines ne sont
peu rentables depuis longtemps et
qu'elles sont condamnées et eux aussi
avec on peut plus se cacher la réalité
il faut mieux avoir mal maintenant et
résoudre ces problèmes
pour cela beaucoup d'entreprises doivent
tout simplement être fermé pour
surmonter la crise financière le nouveau
gouvernement est prêt à prendre le
risque et ne puisse social majeur mais
il n'est pas sûr que ça suffise et qu'il
n'est pas hasard ont péri de crise
en même temps la mondialisation impose
ses règles dans tous les domaines y
compris ceux des voyages et du tourisme
les compagnies aériennes s'associent et
augmente encore leur capacité en signant
des alliances avec d'autres modes de
transport ainsi la compagnie aérienne
américaine united airlines vient de
s'allier à la sncf et ribas tio
christian tu l'avion et le tgv avec un
seul billet dès le 18 juillet les
passagers se déplaçant entre lyon et les
états unis pourront se contenter
d'acheter un même ticket en agence lyon
la part-dieu roissy roissy charles de
gaulle les états unis d'un seul trait
l'accord conclu entre united airlines et
la sncf vise à simplifier les démarches
des voyageurs souvent c'est très
difficile d'obtenir à la fois un billet
de train et un billet d'avion
n'achetez qu'un seul billet pour les
deux c'est une très bonne idée
conséquence l opération à l' agence de
voyage en enfer
moins de complications
on a été levée
ces visiteurs chaque année cent mille
personnes voyagent entre lyon et les
états unis un marché important pour
united airlines mais avant tout c'est
l'intérêt bien compris des deux
entreprises qui est en jeu
beaucoup de nos clients s'attendait dans
le monde entier à pouvoir acheter des
billets de tgv et avoir un billet unique
entre l'avion et le tgv
aujourd'hui c'est fait avec united pour
lyon c'est fait avec air france pour
lille et ont pensé qu tendre cette
formule à d'autres destinations et puis
à d'autres compagnies
le tgv relie 157 ville et le united
airlines s'est associé à six compagnies
mondiales intéressés par le
développement de ce projet d accord
devrait être scellé d'ici juin 99
dans le futur on pourra sûrement relie
d'arcachon par exemple à rio de janeiro
avec le même billet mais pour la
location de la chambre et l'excursion en
bateau il faudra toujours faire appel
un tour operator pour en revenir à la
coupe du monde de football par un autre
biais toute la france s'apprête à vibrer
dimanche prochain en bleu blanc rouge la
preuve
eh bien les ventes de maillots de
l'équipe de france connaissent un boom
sans précédent pascal golomer bernard
les joueurs sont au repos mais les
affaires continue plus que jamais et au
hit-parade les articles estampillés
coupe du monde
le maillot tricolore arrive en très
bonne position longtemps négligée
aujourd'hui très recherché même à près
de 500 francs pièce sur les champs
elysées c'est une chance de la très chic
autant
sorti son mari will à désirer la voix je
cherche aujourd'hui ça c'est pour mes
jambes j'ai des jambes
et puis voilà quoi qu'il en coûte pour
ça aujourd'hui et pour l'équipe de
france est phénoménal pour le budget
familial
on a une arrivée à 1h30 à peu près 200
maillots là ils sont partis mais son
parti maintenant il n'a quasiment plus
là alors c'est cool et quoi 1h30 et 2h30
l'isr est une très bonne surprise pour
la marque adidas qui commercialise le
modèle officiel elle frise la rupture de
stock
alors que les français avaient toujours
boudé les maillots de leur équipe
nationale mais à parcours exceptionnel
des joueurs comportement exceptionnel
des consommateurs
on a vu
supporters argentins les supporters de
tous les autres pays venir en maillot au
stade je pense elle aussi peut-être
montré un petit peu l'exemple comme ça
et puis le parcours après de l'équipe
donc j'espère que ça peut aussi changer
un peu les mentalités après avec les
français n'auront plus façon fier de le
porter au pouvoir mettre dans la rue
c'est que les enfants iront à l'école
avec en septembre tout dépendra de la
finale jaunes ou bleus nike ou adidas
c'est un autre match très attendu les
heures de joie de la nuit dernière sont
déjà malheureusement déjà dû passer pas
tout à fait encore hier soir si les
trois quarts des français étaient devant
leur écran de télévision
il avait tout de même un certain nombre
qui furent involontairement privés de
match mais par tous les moyens vous
allez loire ils ont cherché à se tenir
au courant valérie fournis ou laurent
hamida
tout ça bien de 21h poste centrale
oridion tu as une collègue qui a voulu
voir le match à la télé ont été moyens
du bord il centre thuram faut qu'il
force est d'admettre avance 21h10 la
coupole au dessus j'essaie de vendre
avec 6,8
parce que c'est le seul poste etc les
écaillers attention donc que le camp
hariri tous les quarts d'heure par joe
kay est le résultat d'un cheveu 0 à 0
un patient chercheurs
pour lui cet usage d'autres arrivent
stressés paris vide même rue saint denis
comme une corde à violon tendu fébrile
jusqu'au premier but but de davor suker
ici à sa délit d'abord choquée ouvre le
score pour la croatie à l'otan sur
l'égalisation
47e minute dont les premiers sourires
apparaissent nuit aussi l'espère thuram
refermer comme tous les acteurs de
sauter à trappes
ces pompiers de la 5e compagnie de
portissol se baladent elysées 22h45
le président en est au stade il paris
est en liesse effectivement on est en
finale
nous l'avons déjà dit les femmes n'ont
pas boudé cette coupe du monde de
football et de même plus en plus de
jeunes filles s'adonnent à ce sport
jusque dans les régions les plus
reculées
à preuve ce match qui s'est déroulé au
pérou sur les hauteurs de l'altiplano la
barre en maillot réglementaire mais en
jupe tout de même
eh bien on tape dans le ballon et vous
allez voir
la technique n'est pas trop rudimentaire
rebond contrôle de la tête et tirs buts
ce journal est terminée dans un instant
la météo sophie davant ici même demain
soir vous retrouverez béatrice schönberg
bonne fin de semaine donc
et allez les bleus
je